could you tell us a little bit about who
you play I play Ava a robot in this film
which is quite a different thing I
haven't done that before she is made
well she has a maker who's made her and
he's in the story taken in this young
guy a programmer to go through a Turing
test to see if he's been able to make a
robot that can be seen as human the
Turing test is quite famous as they is
based on Alan Turing yes who we all know
about from other movies and and it
really is to determine that this is kind
of the benchmark isn't it yes which
scientists will use to find out whether
there is consciousness or how would you
describe it yes if you can be if you can
have a computer and then believe that it
has conscience so you're playing aber
yes so you're playing a machine with
these human qualities what kind of a
challenge was done I mean it was it was
really exciting part to take on because
when I read the script I was kind of
intrigued by how it's a very intelligent
script where it's so much subtext so you
know the writer can actually kind of
rely on just having most of the dialogue
there and you read things through the
dialogue it doesn't have a lot of stage
directions so it wasn't really a big
description of what Ava is what she
looks like what's there and how she how
she well acts out those lines so I kind
of were given the opportunity to kind of
have this clean sheet and then just try
to figure out myself who who she is and
of course together with Alex and it was
a lot of conversation of you know
wondering how far to go how much
whatever that is playing a machine how
far away how human you should make her
and then you start a question of what is
human and what is not human when you try
to you know transcend or it likes
speak out line if it's the voice if it's
the way you move the way you look so you
know we did a lot of you know we talked
many hours but I think we kind of if you
see the film now we tried to aim for
something very human to start with and
then it was almost like I tried to find
the offbeat's
trying to make her off keen to for the
audience or for Caleb who is
interviewing her to kind of suddenly
question whatever she does and doesn't
do and then question yeah question what
is human and - not so that question what
is human is it really is at the very
heart of the film isn't it
it is yeah and did you join the process
did it did it change your opinion on AI
and um well it you know it did I think
we are in our society today we're
surrounded by technology we have things
in our everyday life that we kind of
don't even know how they work because
the evolution goes so fast and I
realized when I started to read the
script but also when I you know when I
read articles about in Japan where they
make human looking robots already that
I'm quite scared of them I'm scared of
making technology that maybe would have
the same kind of intelligence or
whatever that is or human abilities as I
have because you're afraid that they're
going to you know evolve and become even
greater than we are I guess I think that
is the fear and then you wonder what is
that fear and that's what I started
question when I made this film and I
started to also read a lot more about
the how the human body and the mind and
brain function and I you know realized
that if you break it down you start to
realize what a great machine our bodies
are and if you break it down into
electrodes and signals in the brain you
even start a question of what emotion
what are human emotions are there just
electrodes to
so in this film you kind of well a very
human feeling is to one you know to want
to be free hmm now you look
extraordinary in the film tell tell me
how you achieve that look I mean I
didn't design the look I mean I think
Alex kind of had an idea of what he
wanted her to look like but I think you
know she it's weird how she looks
strange but you know already when I saw
a drawing of what they had in mind it's
strange but it's something beautiful
about it and weirdly enough it's when I
saw the special effects it was
interesting how I could find those
little you know the machine itself I
could find that beautiful after a while
the way it moved and like the little
lights and things and I think it was
very important you know for Alex that
she looked exquisite and but in
preparation each tale and said how long
would it take you to get ready I am I
think in the end we maybe got down to
three and half but we started with four
and a half and then one hour after we
finished shoot it off so I didn't sleep
much for those six seven weeks but you
know it's worth it it was amazing to
kind of get into even though it was a
pain it was a heat wave in London while
we were shooting it with tin roofs in
the studio at Pinewood and I had like
fallen dust to old fans surrounding me
just to kind of keep my camp temperature
down but you know it was interesting
being in that room because you kind of
forget how you look like when I went to
the canteen one day in ordered food and
suddenly had people looking at me and I
totally have forgotten that I was bald
and had this forehead on top of my head
but then it was the same thing while I
was shooting because there was so many
in like glass walls so I could kind of
suddenly see myself quite often and that
kind of helped to see this strange
little figure you know see myself
without hair
you know yeah it did help it really
worth us an extraordinary look yeah tell
me about working with our they say he's
been involved with film for a long time
now but this is the first time as a
director yeah you can't really you know
believe that he's a first-time director
I knew that you know he's done a lot of
script writing he's been on set working
on other films that he's been involved
in but he is it's something about you
know if there's anything you would guess
that a first-time director comes in
where there's been you know nervous
taking on because it's such you know
when people get to do them it's so
difficult to get films made so it's your
baby and if you given the chance us
directly you want to of course give it
everything but he had such calmness to
him and I think I've ever worked with a
director he's as calm as him and still
so extremely well prepared and it's also
that you know I think my love for
filmmaking is to walk into a room and be
surrounded by great artists on any of in
every department and everyone kind of
gathers because they believe in her
passion to make this vision and he'd
just let everyone do the thing so it was
you know it was a small set a few actors
in this one space and it was a very
enjoyable shoot very few actors really
yeah so let's talk about your your
colleagues Oscar who does he play in the
story just explain how he fits them well
he plays this great kind of programmer
he kind of believe that he's prompt from
probably owns one of the biggest
companies in the world a bit like I
don't know Google or Apple my kind of
Empire and he is he has now because he
can because the very human thing if you
have the ability to do something you are
curious enough to try and go for it so
he's made this robot
and Oscar you know I think he's done an
amazing job with this part because like
for all of us it's you know it is a
thriller you don't really know who the
protagonist is and you kind of question
yourself and question everyone and their
what their wills and thoughts are
throughout the film and you know he
could be his you know it's quite a rough
tough character and but he brings such
sensitivity to it which I think was just
such a splendid thing to do and we
didn't have many scenes together
unfortunately but you do have a lot of
scenes though with Donald don't you and
explain again how he fits into the story
his character he plays Caleb this
programmer who has been brought out to
this house to do to be part of this sean
test to interview Ava to see if he
believes that she has consciousness and
he he in a way is again we're never
quite sure where we are with each of the
characters you're kind of of course with
Caleb you kind of walk into the story
being he's like the bridge yes for the
audience of course you you did some long
tanks on this didn't you yes I mean it's
made you over I did it's a very
different experience because normally
you have you know lots of scenes and but
here we had I think I had about four or
five scenes with Donal all of them ten
and twelve pages long which ended up
being 20 22 minute takes and so it was
almost like preparing for a little stage
play and that also made it possible for
us to kind of try things out Alex had
this thing that he let us do almost
three run takes so we kind of as soon as
we were done no one moved in the crew
just went back to where we started and
tried it again because that made us kind
of be in it and with Donal here I worked
before one you know we had we have good
chemistry since before we know each
other but suddenly you work with
he's always willing to try new things
and because of the long takes we always
ended up going on you know we take one
other decision and then we were when a
total of the route and we ended up doing
a completely different scene so it was
very you know fresh and exciting
you